Jay and Silent Bob are coming back to
spoof comic book movies Hollywood and
more once again in Jane Silent Bob
reboots but what if Jason Mewes in Kevin
Smith's iconic stoner duo did more than
just smoke herb and spoof superheroes
what if they actually went out and
joined the superheroes world it's not as
strange as it might sound Kevin Smith is
directed and appeared on episodes of the
CW's arrow verse franchise and muse has
made appearances on the shows as well
the duo along lend their likenesses to
the Red Bank New Jersey comic bookstore
Jane Silent Bob's secret stash owned by
Smith since the late 90s
you may recognize it as a setting of
AMC's comic book men also developed and
produced by Smith long before the
arrowverse or the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Smith's own viewest universe be
Marvel Studios - the shared universe
concept by an entire decade with Jay and
Silent Bob being the main thread tying
together many different movies Smith's
films have even had comic-book tie-ins
and Jay and Silent Bob have in universe
comic-book alter egos Bluntman and
chronic both of whom are making a return
in the story of Jay and Silent Bob
reboots so Jane sul and Bob of comic
book bonafides
that's been long established but what
would it look like if Bluntman and
chronic joined a slightly more serious
superhero universe what if they suddenly
jumped from the askew universe to
something a little more fantastical we
spoke with Jason Mewes about that
possibility during promotion for his new
movie and directorial debut madness and
the method during our chats we got to
talking about the sweeping next phase of
the MCU which will include the animated
Disney Plus series what if a take on the
classic series of speculative Marvel
comic books considering the Marvel
Comics has in the past crossover with
the likes of Star Trek's transformers
and that's from Evil Dead it's not such
a weird thing to wonder what if Jay and
Silent Bob went out and joined the MCU
if anyone knows the answer it's Jason
Mewes a lifelong comic book fan and
while he may be sober these days he
knows his on-screen stoner character
inside and out I think it'd be like Jay
and Bob or would be like Bruce Wayne
Dick Grayson or earth
14 and then we turn into Bluntman and
chronic so it could almost be like a
what-if news imagines the character's
origin story as being something straight
out of Batman Begins which is DC branded
sure but we don't think anybody's going
to so instead of finding the Batcave
the bats gave were swaying the idea to
dress as a scary bat Jim Bob go into a
cave and like a bunch of weeds in there
and then awesome like there's the idea
will scare everyone with our chronic and
blunt man
in other words move over munites this
dynamic duo would make for a much more
amusing take on Batman style
crime-fighting maybe they can cross over
at the same time as Deadpool yeah it's
me Deadpool and I got an offer that you
can't refuse
of course there's more than one way to
join the MCU technically speaking Muse
already exists in the Marvel movie world
as do Jay & Silent Bob
that's all thanks to the late Stan Lee
who made one of his last on-screen
appearances in 2019 s Captain Marvel set
in the 1990s the movie shows leave
reading the script for Kevin Smith small
rats while sitting on a train memorizing
his lines out loud to himself he also
previously made a cameo appearance in
that movie Smith's second featured in
the cast alongside Jane Silent Bob they
look happy don't they what the brass but
enough of this in universe speculation
let's just get direct about her Jason
Mewes is a working actor so are there
any comic book characters out there that
he'd want to play the answer is well yes
but not that he would exactly accept the
offer to play them I think a vigilante
or Deadshot would be really cool to play
again there too my favorite DC
characters but I don't think I'd want to
play a character because I love watching
the movies the TV shows oh so much music
he is to feel this way in general not
seeming to want to join in on the things
he enjoys experiencing as a fun I think
it would throw me out of the universe if
I'm sitting and watching you know
Netflix's daredevil and I was playing
you know one of the main characters like
even if it was froggy Nelson he probably
means foggy Nelson but give the guy some
credit
froggy Nelson is a real character so
long as you're reading about daredevil
and not daredevil I just I just feel
like I want to gather sit and enjoy
watching it and and really getting it
into the this stuff if I was a main main
character but of course I'd love to be
in any of the
movies TV shows if I was like journalist
number two who like you know got to
interview them one or two scenes out of
the series or once in the movie or
something he doesn't just talk the talk
on his topic either this is more or less
exactly what he said on the our first
series the flash on which he's played
two characters Humvee guy and Jada
security guard
so while you might not seem use head
lighting a superhero show on DC universe
or Disney Plus you can definitely catch
him making hay on his home turf as Jay
and his alter-ego the og chronic you can
see Jay and Silent Bob team up again in
Jane Silent Bob reboots touring row Joe
kicking off on October 15th and you can
also check out Muse reunion with Stanley
if madness and the method check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]